movies like Batman Begins and Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice are full of
scenes lifted directly from the pages of
DC Comics but as the DC extended
universe ramps up towards the next
Batman solo film which is expected to
hit theaters in 2019 director Matt
Reeves has over 75 years worth of Batman
stories to pick from and some of them
definitely don't make the grade here's a
look at some Batman moments that will
never be on the big screen Messiah of
the Crimson Sun
if you've ever wished the James Bond
flick Moonraker had starred Batman
instead Tim boy do we have a story for
you appearing in Batman annual number
eight Messiah of the crimson Sun
involves Rachele Ghul making a giant
space laser but after commandeering a
space shuttle and engaging into zero
gravity karate
Batman defeated the leader of the League
of Assassins by tractor beaming him into
the laser blast considering the days of
High Camp seem to be in Batman's distant
past it's pretty unlikely we'll ever see
this one on screen The Hunchback of the
Batcave was wonderful time in the movies
The Dark Knight seemingly endless
Arsenal's crime-fighting equipment was
either provided by Lucius Fox or made
down in the Batcave by Alfred and Batman
himself it's a pretty good answer as
long as you don't think about it too
hard why nobody down in Lane tech Rd
realizes they spent an unusual amount of
time selling up wearable hang-glider
capes and bat shaped boomerangs is
anyone's guess but honestly it actually
makes way more sense than what we got in
the comics see in the comics all this
stuff came courtesy of a hunchbacked
mutant mechanical genius who lived in
the Batcave and spent his life building
Krabs a Batman this modern-day high-tech
Quasimoto was named Harold Allnut and
while he was essential to keeping the
Batcave operation going he almost never
got any screen time at all until he was
unceremoniously murdered the less said
about all nuts the better trial of the
which one sinner the real reason Batman
and Superman seem to always be at each
other's throats
well one unlikely explanation was
provided in the pages of 1969's world's
finest number 186 where the Man of Steel
and the Dark Knight head back in time to
find out why real-life Revolutionary War
hero mad Anthony Wayne looks like Batman
the answer of course is that they're
related but along the way Superman
claims to be a travelling actor by
announcing that the S on his chest
stands for Shakespeare and then sets
about convincing the good people of 1776
that Batman is a witch
this might seem out of character for
Superman but there's actually a really
good reason for it
he was possessed by a genie obviously
Nocturna hey remember the time Batman
had a custody battle with a vampire over
who got to raise Robin No well let us
introduce you to Nocturna after adopting
Jason Todd who was Robin at the time
this bloodthirsty arch criminal then
tried to convince Batman that Robin
could only be raised properly if they
got married a supernatural rom-com
version of Kramer vs Kramer with Robin
stuck in the middle hey someone called
Katherine Heigl a Christmas story if you
think the story of Christmas begins with
a manger well you've clearly never read
Batman The Brave and the bold number 12
which features the insane tale of how
Christmas truly came to be the story
starts with earth being destroyed and
just gets weirder from there by the end
of it Batman and his partner Adam
Strange end up literally rebuilding the
universe from within a reality altering
antimatter stream coincidentally made up
of glowing red in green balls of light
that twist their body strange ends up
being stretched out and aged with these
were tons bearded appearance imprinting
on the subconscious mind of the refilled
universe creating the idea of Santa
Claus and Batman
well Batman is actually his health
helper please make this into a movie
professor gorilla Batman has so many
iconic enemies from the Joker Catwoman
and penguin to poison ivy
two-face and the Riddler that the movies
just don't seem to have room for some of
his lesser-known adversaries which is
too bad because that means we'll
probably never see professor gorilla in
a movie originally appearing in the
Batman manga by Jiro cuota that ran in
Japan's shown in 8th Magazine in the
1960s professor Barry love was well he
was exactly what he sounds like a
gorilla who gained genius levels human
intelligence and then tried to exact
revenge on the entire human race
hey if they're going to keep making
Planet of the Apes films they might as
well put Batman in one Robin dies at
dawn if you were looking for a great
story that dealt with the psychological
drama of being Batman you could do a lot
worse than to go back to the 1963
classic Robin dies at dawn arguably the
best Batman story of the decade
Robin dies at dawn shows a Batman who's
struggling with the paralyzing fear that
his life as a superhero will inevitably
lead only to more deaths and suffering
specifically to Robin's death which
would cause Batman to lose his only
family a second time this crazy story
begins with Batman's walking aliens in
space before fighting criminals while
wearing a gorilla costume over his
battered so it had that going for it too
unfortunately for one film fans some
things are so awesome they can only
exist in the Silver Age of comics
sorry rainbow Batman and that baby
thanks for watching click the blue icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]